over the past 6 years here on the
fortnite island we've lived through
constantly changing realities and dozens
of world-ending events yet we are all
still here the Big Bang event will be
the conclusion of
2258 days of story building and I'm here
today to summarize and remind you of the
important bits in the story and the
sudden inclusion of time travel I'm
adamaru hello there here's the
summarized fortnite story
line before we can look at the key
characters of the story we first must
pay attention to this ball of energy
this is the zero point the Nexus of life
back in the empty void of space Before
Time began the Big Bang occurred an
unexplained explosion that created every
planet universe and reality in existence
at the center of that was the zero point
a gateway to any and all worlds as life
forms evolved the zero point quickly
became the most desirable object in all
of reality and countless attempts were
made to capture it the orb developed
countermeasures to hide in plain sight
and wipe the memory of any attacker who
came too close but it was only a matter
of time until it fell eventually a man
named Jano took control of the orb
largely due to his superhuman abilities
and a little thing called immortality
jeno was a perfectionist and saw the
zero point as a way to create the
perfect civilization and quickly
established his organization the
imagined order his plan was to take the
best bits of each reality which seems
like a noble idea but he was also
unnecessarily cruel using the 22-minute
loop of a typical Battle Royale match to
force combatants to fight over and over
again these contestants were referred to
as Loopers and that's what you and I
have been doing for six years we are
officially
Loopers jeno was unaware of a fail safe
in the loop program which could free the
last remaining Survivor and return their
memories this led to multiple uprisings
with Batman and Catwoman leading their
own Escape missions As Time passed the
heroes of fortnite's timeline were
introduced seven high-tech Warriors who
made it their life's work to stop IO
free the zero point and keep it safe
from harm as there is seven members the
group called themselves the
seven and this troop of characters spent
their lives systematically fighting o to
free the zero point with almost a 100%
failure rate the imagined order stood
strong for Millennia but nothing at all
lasts forever let's talk about agent
Jones and Dr
Sloan if I had to say who the main
characters of fortnite are I'd say Sloan
and Jones right now they are working
together to time travel back to the
original Island to set the scene for the
Big Bang event they've been around so
long it's tough to to be sure if this
Duo are good or bad right or wrong and
personally I've never trusted Sloan they
began this story as members of the
imagined order responsible for
maintaining the loop in return for
keeping their original realities safe
from harm and the added bonus of
extended life these two are likely
hundreds if not thousands of years old
and one thing that time gives you is
perspective Jones began to question if
he was doing the right thing that
coupled with the anguish of outliving
his family and loved ones caused him to
snap agent Jones switched sides Jones
[Music]
Jones you have a
deal Jones's betrayal began the downfall
of IO as he freed the leader of the
seven the foundation meanwhile Dr slan
stood firm in her role at the imagined
order the ones perfectly in sync Duo
were now at War a war that lasted years
you just had to be the hero Jones the
final showdown between the two ended
with Jones and the Seven destroying a
reactor designed by the imagined order
to wipe out all life forms on the island
she had this coming Sloan got her come
upin you don't have to do this always so
dramatic any last words
Jones um look out
without warning 2 years later it was
revealed that Sloan survived that fall
the time alone giving her perspective on
life and she too left the imagined order
her new life's purpose is the pursuit of
knowledge and answers whilst down here
Sloan stumbles upon an ancient world and
casually makes contact with Optimus
Prime yeah Transformers are cannon in
this storyline the power that once
flowed through your island has faded and
formidable enemies have taken notice the
answers you seek lie deep within the
starless void that brought you here
Sloan quickly understood the subtext
time travel was now possible but
regardless of what we do reality zero is
doomed to collapse and that also
explains why the zero point is currently
petrified and totally useless and after
casually building an astral projector
she foresaw a time traveling vampire
coming to
fortnite weird Sloan then hired a team
of Thieves to Heist the time machine and
now it's hers it was that simple all
along unexpectedly Sloan did not use the
machine to travel back in time herself
instead she reconciled with Jonesy and
they both forgave each other for trying
to un alive one another the dynamic duo
were a team again Sloan as The
Mastermind and Jones as the field agent
just like the old days but this time
under their own free
will
and that brings us up to date fortnite
OG we know Sloan's plan involves the
rocket from 2018 and The Time Machine
from 2023 and quickly any expectation
about changing the future have been null
and void confirmed to be useless you're
back here for a reason and it's not to
change the future by the way drop that
fantasy right now this is an extraction
and you're leading the way the mission
was to send Jones back in time to to
take something not to change something
we see Jones painstakingly dragging the
time machine over to Dusty divot and
strapping it to the intergalactic rocket
ship using material clasps those aren't
going to hold at all as the four weeks
passed in fortnite OG we received voice
recordings from Sloan and this reveals
an issue Jones Sloan here Jones Sloan
here I feel like I've done this before
Jones slown here it's not my first
message is it as Jones drags The Time
Machine around the island he causes time
paradoxes to appear different timelines
begin to merge together not only
changing the OG present but also
changing the future ripples in time
affecting Sloan the butterfly effect in
real time Sloan has only recorded one
message yet she's done that at least
four times culminating in a final
goodbye between the two SL here I've
definitely left this message many times
before so get right to it huh this is
the first time in countless lifetimes
that I don't know what happens next
we're both heading off into the unknown
I guess this is goodbye from this me and
that you but we'll meet again reality is
not done with us yet keep the campfires
burning Jones wherever and whenever you
go you now have the story elements
needed to enjoy the Big Bang live event
this Saturday but with all this meddling
in time anything from the last 6 years
could suddenly become relevant during
the event to be fully prepared for the
future we need to recap everything hit
the OG
music for 277 days we blissfully enjoyed
our Island becoming accomplished Loopers
playing Battle Royale day in day out but
something changed an unexpected meteor
was spotted hurtling towards our home
smashing down causing a huge crator
surprisingly inside that rock was a
visitor literally the visitor the first
time we'd met one of the seven his
mission was to pinpoint the zero point
and Escape without alerting the imagined
order this looked successful as loot
Lake was indeed the place the zero point
was hiding but the cracking reality Left
Behind when escaping changed everything
an unknown faction used that Rift to
awaken a cube of negative energy which
quickly rolled to loot Lake it was here
for the zero .2 but dark energy and
water do not mix the cube dissolved its
second attempt after reforming was also
unsuccessful as the zero point used a
place in between time and space to
destroy the cube we still don't know
what this place was the next event saw
an ice deity freeze the entire Island
this was the Ice King his mission in
life is to capture and contain any
objects of power that could reshape
reality so he froze us all little did he
know the island immediately began to thw
out on day 585 we finally saw the 0
point for ourselves as the Vault opened
but most of us were too busy voting for
the drum gun to notice we then had a
dance to marshmallow as fortnite changed
yet again remember that thoring ice well
thanks to a volcano the Beast inside got
out and rushed to Devour the zero point
luckily the io had commissioned a Mech
to protect the orb and most surprising
of all the PIP pilot is none other than
the Paradigm a member of the seven their
sworn enemy Paradigm was so close to
losing the battle that she cracked the
zero point to overcharge her Mech and
save the island and after a victory
dance she flew into space to find where
that ice creature came from leading to
being disowned by the seven who saw
paradigm's actions as betrayal the newly
cracked Nexus became unstable and both
exploded and imploded at the same time
sucking Jones into another realm between
realities this is where I believe we are
going in chapter 5 but that's a theory
and not a fact so let's crack on this
eruption led to the first time hop in
fortnite as the events of this chapter
were undone and the meteor never landed
here the visitors pod opened again and
this time he built the rocket at the
dusty containers but wait this was not
the same timeline a new member of the
seven was inside that pod the scientist
who likes to do scientist stuff this
thick boy added Tech to The Rock rocket
and on day
748 the end event arrived in an attempt
to get to the io's bridge of control the
seven United to trigger a black hole
event this was the first time we'd seen
nothing reality without reality but we
had nothing to worry about a few days
later the zero point reset and real
reality zero was back new and improved
the most random event ever next the
universe of Star Wars dropped by as
Palpatine was resurrected and we all got
to use lightsabers for the very first
time back then having a lightsaber in
game was truly amazing after A Dance
with Travis Scott the storyline returned
thanks to Midas a character with the
ability to change things into gold he
was secretly building a device which
could force back the storm and extend
that 22-minute cycle m us tried to end
the loop although unsuccessful this
event gave us an insight into the
imagined order as we rifted into their
offices for a few moments meeting agent
Jones for the first time face to face
hear mear me me it didn't last long and
once again we returned to the
loop the next attempt on the Zero Point
came from the Marvel World Galactus
another Devourer of Worlds felt the
power of the orb and raced across
realities to claim it for himself
luckily his Herald Thor was on hand to
call The Avengers in for help and thanks
to Iron Man we won an epic battle
sending Galactus back to his own
[Music]
reality you did it thank you bus
driver and then the day came Jones
switched sides during the zero point
crisis event he now chooses to help the
zero point instead of control it and
finds a way to free the leader of the
seven the foundation following a quick
scrap a deal is made to revive the zero
point the big guy seals himself inside
as Jones is lost to the loop here we
go day,
1411 we learn of a new faction the last
reality these villains use an Ariana
Grande concert to read the minds of
Loopers everywhere and uncovered the
location of the zero point and soon
after arrive to eradicate it the last
reality long to destroy that orb the
leader of the last reality was the cube
King but he is another character to
switch allegiances to the seven becoming
the origin the new ruler of the last
reality is the cube Queen and she is
hellbent on destroying the zero point
the last reality quickly launch a
fullscale attack on the island to get
through this we reluctantly joined
forces with IO and commanding officer Dr
SLO she sends us aboard the mother ship
to plant bombs yet something happens we
were double crossed by Sloan who
sacrifices us to blow up the Mother
Ship somehow we survive this and so did
the last reality and their army of Cubes
we finally understand the origins of
Kevin he was a bad guy all along the
purple cubes begin to duplicate but one
blue cube stands with us the Cube Queen
powered up and the end version two began
the Loopers versus the minions of
Darkness the battle was far from even
the last reality were going to win with
ease so out of nowhere the seven
reappear to the story The Visitor and
the scientists rushing the Loopers to
safety below ground down here the
foundation having been yeed from the
zero point into the DC world has found
his way back to the island and searchy
spot agent Jones freeing him from sl's
clutches in an in genious plan the seven
and Jones flip the island the weakness
revealed by Kevin years earlier was key
all along water H2O is the cube Queen's
weakness the last reality is defeated
for now at least with the island flipped
a new world is here for us to discover
including the home of the seven yet this
Cal wouldn't last
long the imagined order returned more
powerful than ever before using an
industrial drill to get through to this
side of the island their latest Gizmo
eradicates building with just one press
of a button another epic war raged on
between IO and the uprising led by the
seven and surprisingly the uprising was
winning IO was being pushed back and
pinned down so they made one final plan
to end the life of every Looper and
start again they erected the collider
the seven were desperate they needed all
the help they could muster the
scientists searched the Frozen Moon Mo
above our heads for signs of the
Paradigm she was still alive and she
still had the mech the foundation did
not trust her in the slightest but her
skills as a pilot were unmatched
rebuilding the mech the Loopers led by
Paradigm took on the collider well there
Shields down by the time you reach the
island after all they do call me the
legend uh-huh copy that Jon Jones led
the boots on the ground team whilst
trying to push his new nickname as the
legend I'm not sure that will catch on
oh and a quick shout out to peely who
saved all of Reality by bringing us that
slurp juice in the final moments of the
battle the uprising looked to have lost
Sloan and her tank was before
them um look
out the seven had won the zero point was
free but at what cost during the battle
two members of the seven we haven't
spoke about yet made a sacrifice the
imagined and the order in the comic book
run alongside the event we found out
that these two women are the daughters
of jeno io's leader his obsession with
perfection forced him to experiment on
his own daughters after leaving they
devised a way to un alive their own
father a seemingly Immortal super being
their weapon of choice was the zero
point throwing him into the orb should
shred him across a thousand realities
and that's what happened but sadly only
one of the sisters survived saved by
Wolverine yeah that Wolverine the
imagins suffered the same fate as her
father but wait plot twist the creator
of the imagined order was revealed to be
very much alive currently rebuilding
himself across realities maybe in time
for the Big Bang event the zero point
was now freed the entire purpose of the
seven was complete the orb was so happy
it began regrowing the Tree of Life in
celebration the imagined order was no
more everything was perfect yet yet
another faction survived after
all the last reality reemerged from
their swim this time using Chrome as a
weapon The Herald arrived on the island
alongside the mysterious voice of the
nothing using manipulation to recruit
Loopers from our own team we see you're
finally prepared to face your fate the
Chrome was so powerful that even the
seven could not stand against it all
members of the seven are now missing
except one the Paradigm who works with
Jones and the scientist's AI assistant
Amy to use Rift portals to look for
those chromed characters we have
confirmation the scientist is alive but
he's somewhere suffering Amy found a way
to portal herself to find him and on day
1,895 everything came to a head the last
reality
attacked once again the zero point
defended itself exploding the entire
Island and with the help of the Paradigm
zero Fusion began pulling realities
together from multiple times and eras it
was the first time we saw the history of
fortnite interacting with early
snapshots of jeno in his younger days
and we think this building here was used
by the reality Warriors an early version
of the seven the zero point once again
retreated underground but this would be
its final Act The Following Season the
orb became petrified its power de
diminishing day by day things were so
dire that Optimus Prime had to step in
our reality is doomed action must be
taken finally Sloan and Jones have
reunited leaving behind their iio routs
with the time machine in hand the pair
are trying to pull off the greatest
Heist and Escape in history going back
to 2018 to take the rocket ship and
change reality forever right now the
zero point is once again whole and
frighteningly close to the last
reality's Cube what will happen next
I'll leave you with the clues Optimus
Prime left behind I'm Adam you're
awesome I'll see you in chapter 5 the
power that once flowed through your
island has faded and formidable enemies
have taken notice the answers you
seek lie deep within the starless void
that brought you
[Music]
here